David's here to explain how the
sponsorship structure really works at a
fifo yeah because certainly you know
it's you know we all know it's the
governing body of football or soccer
they have events and obviously the most
popular as the world cup so depending on
where you are in this structure
basically is where your name or your
brand comes out and you know you can
take a look at this it's on the website
get the graphic up here which basically
explains the three tiers of where these
names are so that said ok you have fifa
partners very top these are the well
these are the five names include key as
well there by the way you today now
let's take a look at the structure
because it is fairly important because
it obviously depends how much you pay
and where you come out so fifa partners
for example the very top level there
these are the guys which come out are
basically all around the world you know
when it comes to the sponsors the second
tier not sure if easy to properly you
have six to eight yeah give us an idea
of what way through the print is so
small there yeah so FIFA World Cup
sponsors these are the guys who come out
during the actual world cup okay and the
Confederations Cup which I believe i
think is a year before the world cup I
could be mistaken but sponsors here at
based on the website at this level enjoy
strong brand association with these two
global tournaments that use of selected
marketing acted so on and so forth and i
believe the second chair for the 2018
world cup in russia which interested me
in two timing qualifiers are actually
starting right now in asia I think you
have McDonald's in there and budweiser
and when you come to the third that's
where you have the regional support
level now where do these guys come in at
the bottom part they basically also help
when it comes to uh logistics these
events so I mean in other words without
these corporate partners and backers a
lot of these big events won't be
possible now there are lots of estimates
out there how much these guys give but
just look at a global viewership when it
comes to the World Cup final for example
I mean 2014 the most previous one in
Brazil is over three billion people
watch at events so you would imagine of
course you want to be seen but when
something like this happens with these
arrests certainly you know Biggs want to
start backing away ok ery
they're concerned so just to be clear
you have three levels as you said
partners sponsored cup sponsors and
region and then you got the regional
sponsors now have any we've got some big
backers speaking out right I any any
indication that some of these big
backers might pull out not not yet but I
think what's clear is that they have
expressed deep concern not only cuz
they're deep concern this morning it was
visa and Kia and Hyundai who have come
up on top of what we've heard from
adidas and i think i'm not mistaken coke
mcDonald's has also come out i think the
only Gazprom has said that it doesn't
influence their sponsorship in place
through the end of the world cup which
we all know will be happening in Russia
that's rush 2018